tim tebow joining espn's first take as
new steven a smith's foe
uh i have some feedback on this i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
about this team tebow we'll be joining
espn's first take as one of steven a
smith for the network announced thursday
the mid-mannered bible toting tebow will
prove an intriguing foil to smith whose
honor outbursts have made him the face
of espn and in turn given autonomy over
the makeup of the daily tv show the 34
year old teba has worked for espn as a
college football analyst in the past and
is coming off a failed nfl comeback
attempt this summer tebow tried to
convert from a quarterback to a title
with jacksonville under his former
college head coach urban meyer but was
cut before the season he previously told
in the mets minor league system for five
years this guy just wants to compete
he's like saying dude put me in the game
uh uh put me put me in a coach yeah i
wanna
uh i'm ready to play right this guy
wants to compete so espn
getting tim tebow fridays is gonna be
tim tebow mondays is gonna be michael
irvin and then tuesday through thursday
they're going to mix it up okay michael
irvin and stephen when they're together
it does very well right
obviously back in the days this thing
blew up when it was skipped bayless
versus steven a it was popping yes max
good on the football side he's done good
with uh uh you know his uh analysis how
do you think it's going to work out with
tim tebow being on uh first take i'm
going to go to you first
uh
look
i think in terms of stephen a smith
versus tim tebow if those are the two
contenders
i think tebow is completely out of his
league i think in what sport though
anything and everything except for
football okay good and
look what's steven a's first sport
though basketball okay okay so what let
me ask you who knows more about baseball
tebow or uh
but it's for for me i don't even know if
it's the knowledge of the sport
it's the ability to talk and use your
words and then just get out there and
like make yourself heard and then use
all these words and these analogies
don't underestimate but i'm saying
there's a stake in the sizzle i don't
think he got the sizzle he might have
the steak yeah i don't think he's going
to bring the heat to steve you've never
seen him call people out you never saw
him give that one message i got like 50
million views when he called out the
team saying what the hell happened today
like he grilled their entire i hear you
i hear you i don't think he's a
lightweight but i don't think he's on
steve on a serious note are you lobbying
for you getting the job i mean i could
think i could hang i'm stephen a smith
i'd love to give it a shot okay but i do
have respect for tebow i met tebow
uh obviously more than anything i think
a good influence
on the culture yeah or as my friend uh
gerard likes to use i'm the zeitgeist
but i think he's a great dude i think
he's got a good message i think from a
debate standpoint i think stephen a
smith's going to run all over them what
do you mean how much you follow sports
are you one that follows first take all
that or not really no i don't i stopped
watching um football specifically and
and then all of them when they all
followed suit and started doing the
whole blm thing kneeling for the answer
you literally stopped watching oh i
literally were you a sports guy did you
play you're six four you know i was a
dancer
oh my goodness that was a dancer
my my choreographer danced with michael
dance with janet who danced with paula
wow really uh yeah he was he was settled
down
no i don't i don't want to show you
what's happening
so you were joking
no i might like a break dancer what what
kind of dance no i did some popping and
stuff but but eric henderson was he was
he was in michael jackson's uh captain
neo he was in several of janet jackson's
uh uh videos
and um
he was the it guy he was actually so
good that when he was dancing on a set
like a big open it was actually outside
madonna was walking up and down the
aisle looking at dancers and picking
them out she looked at him and she's all
he's too good she didn't want him on
this on the stage with her but he was
phenomenal and so
yeah i just i danced early i was in a
when we got into high school it was
either running around and get sweaty
with a bunch of guys
or dance with all the girls me and phil
so i'm like i'm like i'm i'm dancing and
hey god use that because my girlfriend
uh well jennifer my bride now but my
girlfriend before i met her in high
school uh we were in a we were in a
rally the whole high school was in the
gym like the whole high school so it's a
rally right
and uh i was in the competition group
and it was just i was the only guy
because most guys can't dance especially
in high school i can't dance and keep up
with the girls so there's eight girls
behind me this way and eight girls
behind me this way honestly
yeah he's playing the numbers we're in a
v formation we're tearing it up we
actually learned the numbers uh the
dance routine they just done on soul
train music awards so jennifer before i
ever met her
she sees me dancing she nudges her best
friend and she's like i'm gonna marry
that guy wow
let's circle back to the mid 90s i was
killing bar mitzvah dance floors all
right you don't want no part of this but
you're on like but now you're on
okay let's get back to tim tebow here so
here's your questions here's a question
you got to think about with tim tebow
and uh by the way if you're listening to
this if you think tim can hang with
steven a and you think this is a good
move smash thumbs up
if you say no this is not going to work
put thumbs down if you think it's going
to work thumbs up if you don't think
it's going to work put thumbs down
this is my biggest concern this is my
biggest concern with
this is my biggest concern with this
taking place for first take i don't know
if espn
as a company
will keep a conservative on
history says no okay history says
no
because if you think about what happened
with will kane i thought will kane was
great i liked him a lot yeah but will
kane started kind of talking about i
remember you don't remember him if you
pull up will can you hear me
i've been woken yes
the guy was an absolute
guy i loved him debating and he made
some good uh good arguments
cain i know dean cain's that's right you
know who he is you know who type in
images you know who he is will king okay
yeah yeah he would do his name someone
that i've right
didn't agree with all of them but half
the time i'm like okay he's pushing the
envelope you know whether it was
kaepernick whether it was some of these
things okay i don't know if espn wants
opposing arguments on those types of
issues they fired him he went to fox
okay they didn't keep him there he went
to fox espn doesn't keep conservative
hosts
and if they do if they keep team tim
tebow i think it's a very good business
move
not philosophical move because they're
going to be able to regain some
audiences that they lost over the last
five years
you got to convert yeah but i don't know
if espn's gonna by the way kudos to espn
for giving tim tebow the once a week
kudos for espn more power to you now
let's see if he can he's going to keep
his job no i think it's i think it's
smart for espn to have uh tim tebow on i
think it's very important because he is
college football
you know he could talk about football
non-stop but like you talk about
him going back and forth with steven hey
what stephen a can't talk about is the
mental fortitude of commanding team
commanding other men
in order to go on the field and do
amazing things stephen a has not done
that right so i i definitely feel like
tim tebow can say you know hey man in
the arena you're over here stephen a i
was actually in those rooms i was
actually on that field it's a lot of
like it's a little it's a little bit
different and with his age even though
oh he you know he doesn't know how to do
this he doesn't want to do that he's
like hey stephen a you're making a lot
of money with espn but i was out there
on the field learning talk about the
humility of me going from heisman to
this this this i have no quit in me so
you don't think that tim tebow's going
to say i have no quit in me what makes
you think that i'm not going to outlast
you what makes you think i'm not going
to come back bigger and better and
stronger and faster smarter
that's what i'm honestly expecting from
him i hope he crushes it
by the way i like max kellerman were you
a max guy i was not a max guy really i
was not a max guy yeah
because max tried too hard to be black
whoa that's it because max tried so hard
to be black what does that mean are you
kidding me did you ever want like he was
he was he was trying to be more black
than steven a was trying to be like it
was almost like
i don't know if you have friends like
this like i look i had friends who tried
so hard to be a gangster and they were
not i had so friends who were trying so
hard to be cool and they were not i had
friends who were trying so hard to be a
basketball player and they were not
friends who were trying so hard to be
players they were not did you see that
his personality changed from like boxing
yeah to first take because that's the
first thing i noticed was that he wasn't
the same and he was trying to convert
you know he was a rapper before right
max kellerman you guys being sarcastic
or serious no i don't know that max
kellerman was a rapper i could see him
be able to spit a little max kellerman
was a rapper back in the days he had
bars oh yeah he's actually pretty decent
but he's got a music video i can't put
it up right now because they're gonna
they're gonna but he actually was pretty
decent i just wasn't a fan of my here's
why i'm not a fan of the first take show
on how it was
when bayless like stephen a gave a lot
of credit to bayless he says i was a
nobody bayless brought me up because
bayless was the relevant guy i was a
nobody and it had somebody to go up
against right and they would be right
will kane to me was better than max
kellerman wilkin would destroy max
kellerman stephen a would destroy will
kane but will king could go up again
yeah the challenge is wilkin used to be
a blaze guy he used to be with the blaze
i don't know if you remember what came
from the blaze years ago wilkin used to
work for back
espn brought him on board and then he
went straight to fox will king could end
up being one of these next tucker
carlson type of guys
do you remember when tucker carlson was
a nobody 20 years ago and jon stewart
went on their show and destroyed him and
johnson he used to wear it you guys suck
yeah he says you guys suck you guys are
terrible and look at tucker carlson
today yeah talk by the way you know when
they came out with the data on who they
think can be the presidential candidate
for 2024 you know who's fifth on the
list tucker carlson fifth on the list is
tucker carlson number one is obviously
trump two is uh desantis
three nikki haley nikki haley's three
there's another one
uh yeah and then five is talking across
no chance how do you put tucker on a top
five so uh i don't know listen espn if
you kept keep tim tebow good for you i'm
betting 70
within three to five years tim tebow's
gonna be fired i hope i'm wrong if they
keep them salute to them right and i
hope tim tebow challenges him in
everything kaepernick does everything
mba does everything lebron does because
sports is no longer just sports it's
political so there has to be an element
of sports today that talks politics you
can't just say sports is the sports of
20 years ago no
it's no longer before we move on yeah
unless you're ufc favorite sports
commentator out there he's number one to
you oh yeah yeah stephen how about you
phil he's snoop dogg
they look like my two uncles are out
there not two uncles
you're my favorite guy or gal
uh for what sports sports personality
commentator
oh come on just told you he was uh i
know maybe it's a dancer no commentator
what about that
for football yeah romo
romo was a science boy it was a science
it was just amazing when he was breaking
it down peyton manning's legit he's
hilarious
i like scott van pelt
svp yeah i'm not a fan yeah
but you looked at me like i was getting
like uh you know i know who you were
talking about okay but you looked at me
like i like offended you
because you did i was offended for a
second i was offended
loki who i'm secretly kind of in love
with malika andrews you know who that is
of course pull her up kai malika andrews
malik andrews if you're listening malika
andrews or carrie champion
the fact that i don't even know who
carrie champion is yeah
she is adorable go to that one right
there kai no third yeah boom
are you kidding me
she's gorgeous
if you're out there hit up yeah
we can get on sports we can
talk tinder or whatever you like what
okay
that's not how you that's that's not how
you get the girl bro
that's
fulfilled no shame in no game wow bro
good luck
just saying she's i think she's pretty
damn adorable
this guy's so when she gives her
commentating you you don't listen to
anything she said no i do i listen very
intently so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]